thank yous for
meeting me here yeah of course you know
he's glad we could set aside our
differences
and avoid the war here you know sell it
all right
salute
[Music]
[Music]
no that's too much what are you doing
we're just having a nice little dinner
here all right
well that's just disrespectful oh no not
his head
he had good hair yeah you're done you
already messed up what else what is
what's going on what are you doing now
this phone no no no don't go deleting
this contact
he's not gonna know where to answer it
or not you're finished now that's
that's good look what you did now we
were in the middle of something more
today
and now whatever what's going on here
what are you
that's permanent that's a permanent
silly mustache
oh now he looks like a a sleeping
musketeer that's adorable but it's
it's ridiculous he can't he can hardly
wash that off that's it
whatever where you going what is that
nah what the what do you do
well you're putting me in the game that
doesn't even make sense here that
doesn't even make sense
oh oh anthony oh that's hilarious but
save that for a slumber party
all right what are you no you're
rearranging the silverware that's just
so mean it's it's confusing it's
confusing enough what what the
hair it needed hit me don't do oh well
you know the salad you get a little
pepper so that's good that's so that's
that's not so bad
you finally did something constructive
what are you looking for
what are you you're putting the
silverware back that's good well
that's good now he knows he can go from
outside to inside and that's
oh you put a little zhu in his head
that's good yeah [ __ ]
oh no it actually looks better than when
he came in
if he wasn't unconscious he could go out
on the town so that's good
that's good okay look here you all right
white
wipe off his face yeah yeah yeah get the
mustache while you're at it
because that's the most embarrassing
part oh he doesn't look ridiculous
anymore
oh okay now that's that's now you're
helping everybody
that's good for everybody everybody
likes that nobody wants lettuce on the
floor
all right we done all right you really
turned this around andy
there he's all right and then you garnet
all right
all right he won't even know what hit
him he won't even know that any
oh no no no no no anthony
eddie i can see it in your eyes i can
see it in your eyes you're going the
other way now anthony and he was going
so well
well that's that's that's perverse hand
me i don't even know what what's that
what's that what are you going to do
with that finger
oh yeah no not a wet willy
oh we're going to war andy we're going
to war
we're going to war
i'm telling you vinnie no disrespect to
your daily departed grandmother but my
aunt makes it pasta
forget about it your van lives in this
neighborhood
it seems kind of dangerous what are you
mcgruff the crime dog
come on we're late already
yeah you you say she lives in this house
here
what the [ __ ] is the matter with you
vinny you're being rude let's go
not trying to be rude the lights are off
maybe we
let's come back later okay she's
probably just taking a nap after the
huge meal she just made for us
go in
i don't have the key you should go in
first she said she'd leave it open
vinny stop being selective stroonz and
get in there
all right all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
surprise
[Music]
lydian
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
eight kilos 100
pure grade afghani heroin
[Music]
100 000 us dollars
hold up we should count it first
[Music]
um i guess
you know we're gonna do a straight
counter on this right now count it count
it yeah that's a good idea
should probably do it fast so we don't
make our friends here wait
okay 20 40
60 80 100
20 40. 60 80
200. you know what i'm fast 20 students
okay i'll take care of that one two
three four five six seven eight nine
one two three four five six seven eight
nine one two three four five six seven
eight nine
why are you doing piles of nine it's
faster than tens oh really i do my nines
ten times and then i do an extra pile of
tannins yeah fast
okay you know what we should we should
probably both be counting oh
well this you'll get two at this double
trouble all right and
20 40 69 80 100
[Music]
i'm sorry can you could you plea could
you do something like over there please
it's
a little distracting oh you know what
what's that i got it we could time me
okay we time me counting out a thousand
we gotta take that time
and then we just count money from that
time times 100. yeah so that's those
spindles
no i i got it this is it right here i'm
gonna do a web search
for a picture of one hundred thousand
dollars okay
then you know we'll know what it's
supposed to look like and then we can
arrange our money
to look exactly like it and see here hey
here we go right here look
i mean damn that looks that looks just
like a lot like our money
i think we got a hundred thousand
dollars here folks i think we made it
that is our money
i'm sorry i'm sorry earlier yeah when we
were counting
i took a picture of our money so i could
upload it on yahoo answers
oh damn that's right i just wanted to
see if anyone could verify what a
hundred thousand dollars look like
oh you got it what was i thinking i got
it man go go go go got it
what the hell are you doing man you know
i was gonna try to rain man it
well that's a plan right now that's
right okay yeah here we go here we go
okay
all right yeah yeah i got that i got
that 2046.
99 980.
oh yeah
please no no
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's the joke what i don't get it
you shot that damn fool
[Laughter]
oh yeah no i still don't get it
hey man ain't nothing again this is
funny man
duke can't snitch
man now fake laugh huh that's not real
i could tell no i think it's really
funny
no you don't look at him sitting there
all dead
he was 20 and now he's dead
he's never gonna have a wife of kids now
man what are you doing
wife and kids that ain't funny
his mom and dad ain't never gonna see
him again
no no you're ruining it for me
okay well i guess i just don't get it
then it's just that you shot him
that's all that's the whole thing oh
okay so
oh what the hell is wrong with you you
don't shoot a dude that's already dead
that's not funny
oh wow
yeah yeah i guess i just don't get it
i'm coming
stay where you are what are you doing
thank you
you're not unlocking it we're doing it
at the same time is the problem
no now stop touching it while i do the
live what do you want me to do
just do it now unbelievable killing me
stop it and reset put it down i'm just
holding it take your hand off
the thing i gotta reset the thing look
look at this huh nothing happens if
you're holding it up
everybody knows not to do that because
now it's all triggered in the middle you
gotta hook down to the middle now
stop what take your hand away from the
door
completely thank you
you are gonna get this what happened
what happened though
what happened i don't know what happened
[Music]